toy pendulums are so basic once you get
past the beginner stuff is there
actually anything cool you can do with
them at all why yes in fact there is and
in this video I'm going to take you
through five difficulty levels of
pendulums because as it turns out they
will be with you for your entire flow
Journey Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and in this video I'm going to
show you just how challenging pendulums
get as you increase your skill level but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyrro Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b buus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so I've
said it before and I will definitely say
it again when it comes to pendulums we
underestimate their usefulness in the
POI world seems kind of a simple idea
right you're just letting the POI dangle
back and forth Beneath Your Hand it's
pretty much the simplest thing that you
can possibly do with the poy right
what's the big deal as it turns out this
idea is deceptively simple and I'm going
to show you just how complicated it can
get to swing the poy back and forth as
you combine it with a variety of other
different tricks real quickly before we
dive in if you like videos about pois
spinning and flow Arts you are in luck
because I make lots of videos on those
topics so if you wouldn't mind giving
the channel a subscribe and hit the
notification Bell you'll be the first to
know when I upload a new video it's good
for you and it's good for me please and
thank you all right so without further
Ado let's dive in trick number one
beginner static pen
so real talk this is such a simple trick
I'm not even sure that there's a real
name for it I just kind of made that one
up but this is a very very important
stepping stone and probably the first
pendulum most people play with really
all you got to do here is dangle the poy
back in fourth Beneath Your Hand you can
either do this with one hand or with
both hands at the same time this is
probably the first pendulum that you
pick up when you first pick up PO and as
simple as this seems it actually is
giving you information that is going to
come in super handy for all the other
tricks on this list too just to up the
difficulty factor a little bit you can
try different phasings of this say
having the PO swing back and forth
together or in opposition or you can
take this into a full arm pendulum
taking them around in bigger volume all
of this is going to help you with stuff
further on in the list and with our
introduction to pendulums out of the way
let's go ahead and check out Trick
number two beginner intermediate 1.5s
fun fact I've actually been in the PO
World long enough that I know these were
originally called called one and a halfs
instead of 1.5s why the change well as
it turns out YouTube's original text
entry field for titles did not support
the ability to put in either fractions
or backslashes so when people were first
uploading videos of these tricks they
had to call them 1.5s instead of one and
a halfs and it took off from there 1.5s
are a really critical step though not
only is this one of the first caps that
people learn and most people are not
even aware that it's a cap but it also
creates some of the most interesting
opportunities that we have for
transitions back and forth between
different poy tricks it also doesn't
hurt that the Aesthetics of 1.5s are
such that they bring the poy heads
together in such a way that looks really
really cool I'll admit when I first
learned them what I really wanted was
just to see the poy heads kissing as
they were going past each other but also
too it has to be said 1.5s are probably
the first time A lot of people are
getting familiar with changing the
momentum of the poy as they're
performing a trick going back and forth
between what is essentially a pendulum
and what is 1/ half of a two petal inpin
flower it takes some effort and this is
the first place we learn how to do that
okay so far nothing too crazy but on
this next one we're going to ratchet up
that level of difficulty a whole lot
trick number three intermediate
horizontal stacking yeah so this looks a
lot different from the last two items on
the list doesn't it but don't worry the
the pendulums are still core to it we
just have to look a little harder to
find them just like our 1.5s horizontal
Stacks depend on us being able to change
the momentum of the poy on a dime rather
than going back and forth between a two-
pedal inpin and a pendulum we're now
going back and forth between top stalls
and pendulums and let me tell you if you
can manage that transition on a dime you
are doing a really really really good
job of controlling both your stalls and
your pendulums let's be real it is super
difficult to get perfect lines on these
Stacks but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't try and man when we do nail
those lines oh it feels so satisfying
cool so with our last two patterns we
have been playing around with doing
transitions back and forth between
pendulums and another poy trick but I
think it's high time we got back into
the world of pure pendulums and added a
level of difficulty to them by adding in
another type of Po trick too trick
number four intermediate Advanced
isolated pendulums so I can still
remember the first time I saw my friend
Charlie Cushing do these and just having
it go through my head of how exactly
does this work so the thing is both
hands are moving through an isolated
hand path the difference is they're not
putting enough energy onto the POI for
them to go over the hand and perhaps
even more challenging they're phased
with the POI in such a way as to keep
the poy within the width of that
isolation too and of course you do it
with both hands split time going through
that path and it creates a really
awesome pattern that makes it look like
the hands are switching off which one is
leading and which one is following give
this one a try if you really want to put
your isolations your pendulums and your
anti-bds to the test wow okay so we've
played play around with isolations we
played around with caps we have played
around with a variety of different po
tricks but there is one type of Po move
that we haven't played with yet that is
going to become important right now and
yes that is the world of hybrids trick
number five Advanced pendulum versus cat
ey in all
seriousness this trick so we shouldn't
confuse this with the version of the
trick where the hands are a part putting
together an anti-bd because that is a
much more simple version of the trick no
instead we are keeping the hands
together which means that we have to
phase our pendulum and our cat ey apart
from each other rather than together and
no lie this is really hard it's kind of
similar to sinking up the hands in that
isolated pendulum pattern from our last
entry but the thing is now that we're
using a cat ey instead of a pendulum for
one of them it means we have to change
the speed at which we go through parts
of the pattern and that puts some
pressure on that Pendulum In really
awkward places my best advice on this
one is just that that pendulum hand has
to go up a lot higher than you think it
does in order to keep this clean it also
has to be said I have a hard time
sustaining this one for very long but
maybe you can show me up on it so there
we go po pendulums turns out there's a
lot more to them than meets the eye did
I forget your favorite pendulum based
trick leave me a comment and let me know
what it was
[Music]
this video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
for your support you rock and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you like the content that
I make and you'd like to see me make
more of it easiest way to do that is
sign up to support this work on patreon
you can do that over at patreon.com
drexfactor poo where you can also get
access to some pretty awesome rewards so
go check that out support the Channel
please and thank you and if you just
cannot get enough of that poy pendulum
action I did a whole video on the top
five pendulum based poy tricks that I
think every poy spinner ought to know
I'll go ahead and link to that down in
the description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace